Your game is going to look
awesome on the big screen.
But before we look towards the future,
let's start with a trip to the past.
First you need to be
aware of something called overscan
when you're designing your game.
Overscan refers to a problem with
many older, and some modern TV's.
Basically, some older CRTs
had trouble centering images,
and there was some variability
in how different models did it.
The solution was to center
an image as best they could and
then slightly enlarge it to make sure
it would take up the whole screen.
Unfortunately, this meant that the edges
of the image would sometimes be cut off.
So here, for example,
our Android's feet might not be visible.
Surprisingly, even modern flat
screen TVs suffer from this problem,
although for different technical
reasons and to a lesser degree.
Here's what to do.
I recommend establishing a safe zone for
important content.
Your best bet is to avoid placing
important screen elements within
about 5% from each edge of the display.
Five percent is a rough guideline and
that's because the overscan amount
varies on different television.
Here's how that might look
on a 1080 pixel screen.
We could add a 96 pixel
margin on the left and
right edges and a 54 pixel margin
on the top and bottom edges.
This is just for illustration.
Check out the instructor notes, for
more details on the specific
margins you should add.
If you're designing a TV app, then you
don't need to worry about over scan if
you're using lean back fragments.
For example, the browse fragment you
see here automatically applies overscan
margins to your layouts.
If you're building a game that will run
on both a mobile device and a TV, then
at run time, you might want to detect
what type of device you're running on so
you can adjust how
the screen's base is used.
You can do this using
the UI Mode Manager.
And there's more details on this in the
building TV app section of this course.